STUDENTSBED TOTH TFO
PATROLS AND 14OR
GENERAMM STU
POLICE SAY THERE IS ACTIVI
HAPPENING HIS THAT
THE PUBLIC ISN'T AWARE OF. FRO.
COLLEC OF EVIDE
SCENE OF A QUADRUPLEFIWED FROM
AT T C SCENE.
YET, THERES USPECT>> IERA IMDOE
T WE'RG IS THA
>>epEEE STABAND WE'RE RECEIVINE
FOUR PEOPLE, THE IS
EIN
T THIS WAS ATA.OINT TO ROOMMATE
NCE THEY
SAY THEY CAN'T ME .
>> WE HAVE INSIDE THE C.
SO WFEELFIDENTTHS  Ieporter: ST
IDARR A VIGIL
WEDNESDA CAMPUS.
SCHOOL OFFICIALTELL C
ADDAHO LIST THROUGHTIN 14 PAOL S
LOCAL PO.
>> WE HAVE O ANYASKED.
S OF
WHAT WE'VERED BUT WEANT TO
SEE THE PERSHO DID THIS.
WE WANT  TUG
>> Reporter: CALL FOR WELFAR
CH HD COMPARED TO
LASTONTH.
WHE THE
CRIME REMAINITY, REMINRSTH
>>IZ THERE IS NO
SUSPECT ID
DE
WHATE  WANT OW, WHILE THEY MAYT
FICERS AT THE SCENE, ATORS WORK
JOHN, THE
UNIVERSITY SAYS ROHLY TWO-THIRD
HAE BACK T
ATTEND CLASSESTHERE IS ALSO GOI
STUDENTS HERE  T TO BEN ATTENDA
LEAST TO COME  THADIFFICUL?
H FOW IDAHO.
REPORTING.THE HOMICIDE
CASE.
'RLLOWINE
FRIDAY. GIRL WERE N RANDPARENT
THSUT
SHOOT-OUT.
LI THEAR-OLD
FORMER VIRGINIR  SCAMMING THE
ONLINEETENDING TOMEONE
HE W TRAVELED ACROSSY TO KIDNA
TO MORGHM JOHN.
FORMER NYPD DEPUTY
IS OF INTELLIGENCE ANDCOUNTER TE
YOU .
SCENEHE HOUD RE THE RELATIVES
THEN TAND THE
YOU  MOST CHALLENGIN
PLACE, AS IT WERE, IS TH
DI EVEE ENE, WHE EVIDENCE
LARGELYD, THERE IS A
PRROUGH THAT AND  IS
THE MEDICAEXAMINER, THIME ENE P
THE CRIME SCENE THAT YOU CANEEZ.
THE DIGITAL CRIME SCENE IS
REALENGE BECAUSE YOU'R WHOO G W
COUNTRY.NITROOPE CONVEIOON
WAS IT WEEKS, MONTHS, WHAT PLATE
AND WHICH, JOHN, THIIS THE WHIC
SE MIAL AS THE
SO IN ANE ONS.
THIS.E PROVIDASASN Y ARE.
ANTIMEER
ANRCANT.RNE.
E ISE PROVIDER
DOS TO THE I GO YOU.
IFISNEE APPSCH
Y
HAD IT IN T T FOR VERY LONG.
SO CATFISHINGA TERMHAR AUDIENC
AHIS COMPORT WITH
ITION?SHING AS IT, IN
THE WORLNES,
THE ROMANCSCAM.
CO
SOMEONE.
R COUNTR
VERY YOU
OU'RS INCREDIBLE PERSON
U TO.EI
CONFIDENANENCY HAPPENSAND YOU A
DOLLARS. TO SE
N OPERATION.RIBLE DENT
SE, THERE IS NO MONEY
R ON
ND YOU.
YOU KNOW, BUILDING HER UP AN
AND IT SOUNDS, TVIDUAL IS FF
WHO LE THE VIRGINIPOLICE, JOINE.
OTHER CASE I
VICTORVILLE, CNI IN JULYA
38-YEAR-OLD MAN PLAYA O A 15D G
INDIVIDUAL TALKING TA O IVNNSYL
AN LATERVEG
STEP TO GO INTO AA BLITATCK
FAMILTHIRE  EVED
T